sie alle wollten eigentlich traditionell
am ersten januar an baden und wurden
plötzlich zu lebensrettern auf den
philippinen wird ein junger mann an
neujahr im wasser von den wellen
umgerissen das wasser ist so stark dass
es ihm nicht gelingt wieder auf die
beine und zurück zum ufer zu kommen
verzweifelt ruft er um hilfe während er
immer wieder von den wellen getroffen
wird andere strandbesucher bemerken
seine notlage und kommen ihm zu hilfe um
nicht selbst unterzugehen formen sie
innerhalb kürzester zeit eine
menschenkette schnell kommen 30 menschen
zusammen die mit vereinten kräften den
in not geratenen mann an land ziehen
die rettung gelingt und der man kann
wenig später von ärzten versorgt werden
die polizei warnt touristen immer wieder
das meer nicht zu unterschätzen mehrmals
sind in den letzten jahren hier menschen
schon ertrunken